ce tuto parce que tu es mais tu peux
lancer tout de suite que ta première ta
première télé c'était le même sur NRJ12
ma première télé en France à peu près
tu es pas connu je me souviens du mal
voilà
aussi oui oui il était là aussi c'est
sur moi là
il peut être un petit peu sur moi et
donc du coup oui je suis un petit peu
ton ton Michel Drucker
alors je vais dire oui je vais dire que
tu m'as lancé tu vas lancer ma carrière
alors beaucoup près je vais dire que tu
as lancé ma carrière on faisait sur la
coupe à Gata on s'arrange Yanis vraiment
vraiment je t'aime beaucoup tu as
explosé
que toi l'ouverture n'est même plus que
les autres élèves enfin voilà quoi
c'était vraiment vraiment génial alors
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas 34 ans
beau gosse spécialiste de talons sur
talon jazz street jazz formation danse
bien sûr et puis en 2013
il y a une copine qui te propose un
petit truc de danser en talon tu relèves
le défi tu postes ça sur Youtube et ça
fait des millions de vues regarde
[Musique]
ma playlist
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est en 2013 fallait déjà aussi un
culot de dingue pour danser en talon et
tout ça il y a pas que le talent il y
avait aussi le courage il y avait aussi
quand ça fait des millions de vues
qu'est-ce que tu dis tu as 22 tu as 20
ans
il faut en fait il faut savoir que
c'était le début de YouTube et des
vidéos qui ont enfin même le mot viral
n'existait pas tant que ça et
puis nous on s'amusait vraiment je veux
dire moi je me rappelle très bien avoir
appelé media Arnaud pour leur dire et
les mecs demain on prend nos valises on
fait donc tout Paris mais de lait sur
l'espace girls mais non ah bon ouais
ouais je suis sérieux ok Let's Go et ça
c'est vraiment fait comme ça et c'était
fun et et c'est devenu
on dansera en string devant les
Invalides demain
si ça peut être viral ça s'enchaîne pour
toi ouais tu fais la France a un grand
talent en Angleterre
final voilà on a les images aussi mais
on va pas passer que des images que tu
es formidable et après même là tu
côtoies les grandes stars tout le monde
t'appelle le téléphone sonne Céline Dion
on t'appelle là on a un extrait tu es
dans le clip de Céline Dion quand même
[Musique]
on t'a pas vu là
en vrai c'était pas moi mais d'accord
d'accord et c'est Deadpool effectivement
je connais pas très bien tout ça elle
est comment en vrai Céline
très très très professionnel on y arrive
toujours aux mots non vraiment très
professionnel moi je suis resté avec
elle de
midi à 2h du matin et elle a dû prendre
un petit break de 1h max elle marque pas
et sympa l'exigeante elle est très
gentille elle est un petit peu folle
mais dans le bon sens c'est à dire que
je m'attendais à ce qu'elle soit
tu sais pas un petit peu plus
et à tout moment ça part une blague moi
j'avais eu des petits énervements quand
j'ai bossé avec elle que quelqu'un avait
fumé dans le couloir elle déteste sa
cigarette la fumée ça se dit la bouquin
dans québécois et elle sort de la Loge
qui sait donc j'ai mis de la bouquin
dans
tout le monde avait une clope comme ça
voilà elle était très mais c'est pour
savoir c'est pour ça et vous avez coaché
Mariah Carey alors là écoutez-moi bien
Yanis écoutez bien
Michel Drucker et Yanis allez petit toi
parce que c'était toi parce que je t'ai
lancé si tu me dis que Mariah Carey
est hyper sympa et perfectionniste là
vraiment c'est que tu es donc des
langues de bois on a plus rien à faire
ensemble
est hyper sympa oui moi je m'entends
très je me suis très bien entendu avec
elle on est un peu le même humour
perfectionniste je pense en studio
sûrement dans la vraie vie un petit peu
moins voilà c'est-à-dire elle est divace
c'est sûr mais elle a elle a tout pour
aussi elle a le droit d'avoir ce statut
de diva ça reste Mariah Carey oui et
après
on devait commencer à 18h elle est
arrivée à 1h30 du matin
elle a déjà fait des choses comme ça
mais
6h30 de retard c'est je sais pas c'est
pas un manque d'élégance mais mais moi
j'ai écouté moi je m'entends vraiment
bien avec
numéro de téléphone
vraiment tu peux l'appeler comme ça et
c'est une BIGSTAR et me dis pas moi
parce que je t'ai lancé
il a une pompe Grey's Y's
c'est la seule les autres j'ai travaillé
mais non c'est pas assez euh
bébé
et moi tu as mon numéro tu as pas appelé
depuis deux jours je crois
alors on va continuer un petit peu et
vous parler de Madonna et vous dites
madonna a changé ma vie je serais pas ce
que je suis s'il y avait pas il m'a
donné ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
ma plus grande inspiration c'est Madonna
bon c'est pas la meilleure photo non
merde mais oui ça veut dire que ça veut
dire ce que ça veut dire je serai avec
pas qui je suis sans Madonna j'ai grandi
devant
c'est la première
c'est la première fois que j'ai vu deux
hommes s'embrasser c'était une bête wood
Madonna d'accord Faudel c'est le un des
premiers DVD où je suis devenu
complètement obsessionnel et j'ai dit à
ma mère tu verras je vais faire ça enfin
je comprends très bien moi je suis avec
Hervé Vilard donc je comprends
parfaitement que tu dis est-ce que
typiquement surtout aussi est-ce que ça
tournait vous y croyez parce que d'abord
vous la voyez maintenant sur les réseaux
sociaux et que même sa fille dit
attention ma maman est sous l'effet de
la drogue il faut l'aider aujourd'hui et
le prendre je sais pas quoi des produits
c'est sa fille qui le dit hein appelle
au secours et est-ce que ça tournait
vous y croyez je pense que ça tournait
elle sera annulé au bout de trois jours
non j'y crois ça tournait j'y crois
parce que je pense que bon déjà c'est
pas sa première donc je pense que
[Musique]
je vais être raisonnable et ça va
paraître bizarre parce que évidemment
que ça serait genre mais très
honnêtement je pense que j'en serais
même pas capable
que je serai là Go qui serait sur le
côté de la scène comme ça en fait tu
sais quoi faut jamais rencontrer ces
idoles exactement j'ai eu l'opportunité
de la rencontrer et
au-delà de l'avoir vu en concert plein
de fois et on m'avait conseillé de pas
le faire et j'avoue avoir
il m'a dit que de vous
alors on va pas aller la Star Academy
quand même parce que vous avez explosé
explosé dans la Star Academy mais déjà
j'ai parlé un petit peu d'actualité
aussi parce que c'est important vous
êtes très très militant évidemment
contre l'homophobie c'est très touchant
je vous ai même vu sur BFM sur des
chaînes d'info pour en parler parce que
maintenant vous avez un impact auprès
auprès des jeunes et bravo vous avez
suivi le petit scandale autour de Bill à
lassani qui devait chanter dans une
église qui n'est plus une église
aujourd'hui
voilà Jean-Michel Jarre a chanté un
autre dame Laurent Voulzy dans des
églises et il a dû annuler sous l'effet
de de on va dire de de pression
catholique très extrême qu'est-ce que ça
évoque pour vous ça bah ça me fait
penser à Madonna tu vois c'est à dire ça
me fait penser à Madonna quand elle
avait été interdit au Vatican à l'époque
de blonde Ambition Tour
c'est d'accord il y a plein de choses
c'est pour ça j'en reviens souvent à
Madonna parce que elle a elle a un peu
militaire avant tout le monde et ouvert
les portes pour beaucoup donc tu es
religieux toi non pas du tout pas du
tout d'accord et je aussi tu en as
beaucoup parlé l'homophobie et tout ça
on va pas passer l'extrême BFM parce que
tu en as beaucoup parlé mais vraiment
vraiment encore une fois bravo c'est des
gens comme toi qui font avancer vos
portes générations futures mais je
trouve ça normal moi j'ai 50 ans c'est
pas moi qu'on va agresser est-ce que
pendant la Star Ac en plus tu n'enfant
talon tout ça c'est une TF1 c'est une
scène posée c'est une chaîne voilà les
gens t'ont vu arriver premier ouverture
danser en talons est-ce qu'avec les
prime tu as reçu des des des des mots
homophobes des menaces des machins
est-ce que tu as tu as reçu sur les
réseaux sociaux est-ce que tu as été
surpris peut-être par des réactions
encore en 2023 13 homophobe surpris non
non et euh oui il y a eu des réactions
mais pas plus qu'avant enfin je veux
dire c'est mon quotidien c'est c'est
[Musique]
ma meilleure photo maintenant là il
allait au KFC il allait déjeuner mais
c'est rien du tout c'est une tenue
normale je suis pas c'est pas une photo
ça mais là c'est très Madonna justement
sur la sur la finale de la saison tu
fais partie des gens qui pensent qu'il
faut choquer un petit peu provoquer un
petit peu pour entre guillemets éduquer
les gens et faire avancer la société où
il y aller tout doucement parce que toi
tu provoques un petit peu quand même
salon et je pense pas qu'il y a besoin
de choquer ou provoquer je pense que
c'est de base c'est qui je suis enfin je
suis rebelle je l'ai toujours été j'aime
pas
mais profondément j'aime pas être
habillé comme quelqu'un j'aime pas
ressemble à quelqu'un j'aime pas je veux
dire je me rappelle même quand j'étais
gamin qu'on me disait on a tous acheté
ça ce jean là et ben je l'ai regardé
comme des ploucs parce que pour moi
c'était des moutons et j'ai toujours été
comme ça donc c'est plus ce côté de la
chrono la différence que de choquer j'ai
l'impression de voir Benoît mais vous
êtes les deux mais pareil parce que
Benoît collection de talons à 4 ans il a
toujours prenait la différence pardon
mais il est dans une petite ville
habitants si tu le veux bien je ne fais
jamais faire un artiste quelque chose
sur scène pas sur scène sur la plateaux
télé parce que je fais pardon mais je
suis aussi artiste c'est sur une scène
non mais pardon oui bah je le suis j'ai
fait beaucoup de scènes pas des boîtes
de nuit des bookings
ça faisait un mec de hauteur
enchanté le petit bonhomme en mousse
avec Jean-Mi mais c'est de la
tête quand même
on en parle un petit peu parce qu'il
faut que je prenne un petit pourcentages
mais pour l'instant les talons sont là
et ont été choisis totalement au hasard
pour leur grâce et leur distinction
Maxime gueny et Jean-Michel maire
oh là là vous allez les gars n'oubliez
pas un mannequin c'est quelqu'un de beau
et quelqu'un de beau emmerde les moches
donc tu ne souris pas
bien OK
[Applaudissements]
alors là déjà rien que le plateau est
très énorme
voilà voilà et vous savez vous pouvez
les garder
[Rires]
vous pourrez les garder pour chez vous
c'est un beau cadeau de la maison très
serré c'est du 44 vous m'avez dit vous
savez quoi
alors on va y aller attends ne vous
cassez rien parce que Jean-Mi il a quand
même alors toi tu vas y attendre
alors tu viens là alors Yanis est-ce que
tu peux juste me faire à pied une
démonstration
tu me montres comment on fait un défilé
le sourire le machin tu reviens quand
même
s'il te plaît musique let's go
musique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais c'est bon ça merci
OK
[Applaudissements]
alors tu réserves ta note tu réserves ta
note on peut être
on peut être surpris
je te le dis ça fait un petit moment que
tu fais plus de télé je sais c'est ton
moment c'était Jo d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
sur chacun et est-ce que ce genre de
chute est déjà arrivé à moi non
mais c'est déjà arrivé
du coup je pense que le gagnant
[Rires]
mais pourtant tu es parti avec tellement
de motivation
tu sais vous savez ce que c'est la
conclusion il faut rester self en talon
s'il vous plaît on écoute Yanis
je peux je peux t'appeler Jean-Louis et
ben non Jean-Mi c'est bien faut juste un
de mes jambes autant de plus les gens
mais je t'ai surtout vu courir pour
vivre non mais c'est surtout avec
l'arthrose c'est marrant on les jambes
toi mais pas mal allez il faut pas
regarder par terre aussi et vous savez
ce que c'est la conclusion le jeune
court vite le vieux connait le chemin
avant de faire le gros doute il y a une
phrase de toi que j'ai adoré parce que
ce que j'aime aussi chez toi c'est qu'il
y a un petit côté prétentieux mais
attention quand on est prétentieux et
qu'on ne dit talent moi j'adore c'est
souvent les prétentieux cons que moi non
je vous emmerde mais mais après il y a
prétentieux et confiance ça c'est pas
tout à fait mais j'ai adoré ta phrase
quand on t'a demandé est-ce qu'il y
avait un petit peu de jalousie avec les
autres profs de la Star Ac et tu as
répondu en vrai il y avait pas de
jalousie parce que il y avait pas de
débat j'étais là ils étaient là
je l'ai pas dit comme ça mais c'était
c'est vrai il y a pas de jalousie
je pense que vu vu que j'ai eu déjà un
tableau d'ouverture et que j'ai et que
les autres n'ont pas été
ça je pense qu'il y avait la compétition
était perdue d'avance dans le sens où je
suis arrivé en force et que bien sûr et
que c'était foutu quoi pour eux
on leur fait des bisous
ils vont tous revenir l'année prochaine
la vérité
c'est que je pour l'instant je sais pas
du tout je sais pas du tout tu négocies
maintenant donc mais très sincèrement je
te le dis et pour l'instant je sais pas
si tu n'es pas là on ne regarde pas je
te le dis est-ce que je peux te poser
une question il y avait des salaires qui
est sorti dans la presse tout ça ou
c'est vulgaire mais c'était quoi c'était
vulgaire
mais je trouve ça un peu enfin si vous
en parler souvent ici mais je trouve ça
un peu type de parler des salaires enfin
vraiment le chips si tu veux
tu veux savoir comment
50000 euros pour les 7 semaines pour les
7 semaines je trouve que tu les vaux
largement
et puis merci de me le dire c'est très
honnête j'adore les gens honnêtes je
t'aime encore plus merci Alice